from that she's going to talk about some
vacations up pretty good okay thank you
very much thanks I don't know thank you
for inviting me to talk in this workshop
now as many of you recall from the
bootcamp what I had set out to do many
years ago and I was thinking about
privacy and technology was to because
I'd been reading the philosophical
literature and of course seeing many
complaints that people were making about
information technology and how it was
challenging privacy and so the goal it
was to come up with a definition or an
account or an understanding of privacy
that was a society society concerning
sense of privacy it needed to be a
definition that would connect with what
people were worrying about at the time
and we know that some of the older
definitions that or at least I
considered some of the older previous
philosophical definitions of privacy
which might have been fine for those
periods of time was were no longer
adequate to the kind of threats that we
were we were experiencing with
information technology and out of this
concern came contextual integrity now
again some of you may never have heard
anything about contextual integrity you
probably won't be able to remember any
of this but hopefully some of the
results that I'm going to talk about
will be meaningful to you some of you
may have heard me talk in bootcamp some
of you may have read and don't remember
so this is sort of a refresher so that
at least something stick in your mind
the main idea behind privacy as
contextual integrity is that privacy the
way people think about and value privacy
is not that they resist or resent or
feel their privacy is being violated
about any information flows what we care
about what people care about is
inappropriate
formation flows and so that if you just
forget everything about contextual
integrity the only thing you need to
remember is that privacy is appropriate
flow of information and then there's
more that the theory has to say
appropriate flow is flow that conforms
with this thing this this concept that
is a construct of the theory which are
contextual informational or privacy
norms and if you want to speak
colloquially it means that it's flow
that meets privacy expectations
now privacy expectations as anybody who
has read the for example the legal
literature is a fundamental concept in
the way courts understand violation of
privacy the question that the judges
will ask are does this practice or this
this policy or whatever happened meet or
violate reasonable expectations of
privacy and so this theory then tries to
map on and inform determinations of
expectation of privacy and these norms
the the the proposal of the theory and
this is a substantive claim of the
theory need to be expressed you need to
have five parameters expressed values
for the five parameters there's an
active parameter acting in a contextual
role or capacity subject send a
recipient information type grown from
the contextual ontology and something
called a transmission principle which is
a constraint on the information flow so
that's part one call it the descriptive
part of contextual integrity but there's
also a legitimacy part of contextual
integrity which basically the idea is
that if you want to establish that a
norm or practice if a prep if you want
to establish that a practice is
legitimate or meets expectation the
first round of analysis is that it
with an existing or an entrenched
information informational norm but
sometimes you don't even have a norm in
a world in which there's technology that
is radically altering the way
information flows and sometimes you have
a practice that challenges an entrenched
norm challenges an expectation and yet
the the population starts to think that
the practice is legitimate but the
entrenched norm is not and I mean if you
think of a dramatic case you could think
of slavery which was a norm and then we
evolved to recognize that the that this
was no longer legitimate and we changed
the practice and ultimately the norm
changed as well and contextual integrity
offers an analysis of legitimacy that
has three rounds so the heuristic is
that we if you if you want to apply
contextual integrity to a particular to
a given practice is you want to
establish what the relevant privacy
norms or expectations are in that
universe of activity you map the flows
the practice in terms of the five
parameters and you check on four months
of flows with norms and expectations and
when you do you say yeah it conforms it
respects privacy no it doesn't conform
what are we going to do about it
red flag is raised and you might even
say they just aren't any norms that
apply here and and and in either of
these conditions you need to perform
that legitimacy analysis to either
sustain the practice and accept you need
to change the norm or you reject the
practice because you said that it's
unjustifiable so that's where I was and
I thought is the isn't this a beautiful
philosophical theory presented this I
was part of a big and
self grant presented it at our one of
our group meetings and John Michell
approached me and he said oh this is
really interesting we can actually give
a formal expression to these contextual
informational norms and one of this is
actually not from that initial work but
I then worked with Anupam data and Adam
Barth and John Michell and they they
then developed a version of linear
temporal logic that can take contextual
norms and express it formally in that
way and this is a way that they have and
and then they actually went through the
HIPAA privacy rules and found that using
this formal language they could express
all the HIPAA privacy rules more or less
okay so then I was excited and I became
very ambitious and I thought yeah well
you know we can solve all the privacy
problems in the world using contextual
integrity you know I was young and naive
but my hopes expanded a little bit not
only that meaningful privacy that
contextual integrity should account for
meaningful privacy that is a societally
concerning sense of privacy but also
that we could use contextual integrity
in digital technology we could design
digital technology respecting because we
now have a formal expression of privacy
rules and we could embed those or
express those who represent those in the
digital technology and well maybe even
mathematical concepts so this is my goal
for the rest of the semester this and
copii is going to teach me how
eventually after many hours of
discussion I'm going to figure out the
relationship but
but for the time being I'm not going to
address the mathematical concept part of
the applications but rather this now is
how we're going I'm going to frame the
rest of my remarks today so what it
because now there's a lot of work going
on in this arena of applications of
contextual integrity and I can report
that ci has been used in a variety of
ways or it has been applied in a variety
of ways to address and give insight into
some active privacy puzzles and
phenomena we just we've applied it to
discover existing norms in society that
is to give some flesh so if a judge has
to decide does this practice conform or
violate reasonable expectation of
privacy
they don't necessarily just have to sit
back and kind of dream it up in their
imagination but maybe we can provide
some empirical backup to that question
we can use contextual integrity to
inform technology design in it
development for we can use it to
communicate law policy practice and
technology and oh my god a double
sentence oh sorry no tisn't excuse me
and we can use it the legitimacy part to
legitimate certain law policy practice
and technology some of the applications
that are that I'm going to talk about
are comforting to me as to say that oh
you know these results are showing that
there is something valuable in
contextual integrity and they help to
test and refine in theory it's not such
a mature theory that we put it out into
the world and we say here's theory
here's application and so it goes but
the application the activity feeds back
and helps to refine
theory and then we're beginning actually
to talk with one or two companies to see
how we can apply contextual integrity in
the real world of Technology and policy
that were already has been a little bit
in the White House the previous White
House consumer bill of rights privacy
rights so some of the applications that
have we've already been pursuing some of
the policy oriented that that used the
ethical enormous normative analysis has
to do with for example learner privacy
in MOOCs and online virtual platforms
biosensing which is wearable quantified
self technology we have a study of the
NSA's bulk telephony metadata program
and a very early study which I'm still
very pleased about was just this
question of posting court records or not
and i think this really i mean it's it's
a distant connection but it's really
connecting it connects with Mica's last
slide about tiered access to some like
one way of addressing policy is to
provide tiered access but i won't say
more about that we have privacy and
technology policy and technology
oriented applications and then there's a
review of a lot of other work in
computer science that uses contextual
integrity so what i'm going to do today
because i'm certain you're not going to
go through all of that in the time that
i have is really a taste of a few of and
in particular some of the very recent
work that hasn't yet been published some
of it is quite rough and i hope you'll
bear with me as i as i try and describe
it what i'm gonna do
is talked about a technical project
which is a systems project that some
colleagues have developed that's and I'm
going to be very brief on that because
if you ask me any questions I will not
be able to answer them in the spirit of
true collaboration I'm going to talk a
little bit more about a series of three
empirical studies one the final one on
location data and again I think there's
a nice connection here we're we haven't
completed we're about to submit and then
finally a quite a neat project on
analyzing privacy policies using the
contextual integrity parameters I I'm
just very grateful to be working with
amazing collaborators here are some of
them and their parts of all the
different projects that I'm going to
describe so the first one this is the
one where we're we've created a system
for extracting and enforcing contextual
integrity norms in bodies of
communication and it's a system called
vaccine and I mainly just pointing it
out to you in case you're interested in
following it up and and reading the the
paper itself it's about to be presented
at the world wide web conference in 2019
and it doesn't really talk much about
the normative part of the theory but it
starts with what we've kind of
colloquially be starting to call the CI
tuple which are the five parameters used
to map flows and express norms and the
idea is again we discover norms or rules
using the CI tupple we map actual flows
of information we match the flows with
the norms and then we alert or enforce
the managers of a system and this is
these are
two parts of this vaccine project the
one now sometimes the the norm can be
extracted from explicit rules a rule
book sometimes and we've we've rarely
been working on this effort which is to
try and crowdsource norms in very
specific contexts and come up with a
bunch of privacy rules and these then
enter into this enforcement system which
would look at bodies of in this case
text to extract actual it's actually a
huge corpus of jeb Bush's emails I think
it was two hundred and fifty thousand
emails that Jeb Bush released when
Hillary Clinton's emails were discovered
and he said look I'm so transparent I'm
releasing all my emails to the to the
world Hillary's was thirty thousand his
was two hundred and fifty thousand and
it turned out there was actually quite a
lot of stuff he really shouldn't have
released in those emails but anyway we
were using that as the basis for our
analysis privacy rules these rules so
these were rule that this particular
part of it we we was were rules that we
try to extract from a crowdsourcing
experiment and Mechanical Turk but then
we also supplemented that were and these
were FERPA related so we supplemented
that by FERPA rule book that had been
generated by letter NYU in that case but
we had also done some crowdsourcing they
performed some logic on it and came up
with a set of rules
it could be something like a professor
should not share student grade with the
parents and this they have a pair of the
students permission for example ok so
now I'm going to move to the part that
I'm feeling much more comfortable with
but to be continued is the series of
three empirical studies with a colleague
mainly with Kirsten Martin and tell you
that the the initial motivation for
these studies was our concerns and now
maybe you'll understand why I pushed you
back on this idea of sensitive data that
the that the dichotomy of private public
was doing too much work
in privacy and in fact some theories
were really based on it to say that when
it's public anything goes but when it's
private or sensitive now the privacy
rules need to come into play and so we
we were challenging this dichotomy in
these three three series we also were
mindful that there are certain puzzles
that are often presented within the
privacy community one being for example
this privacy paradox where as everybody
knows the idea is that you give people a
survey they say yeah privacy is really
important we love privacy but then when
you when you watch their behaviors it
seems like they don't care about privacy
at all and we one of the things that
concerned us is that people are just
asking the questions in the wrong way so
the first in the series of studies was
privacy interests in sensitive
information and I'm only going to show
you this this I had already discussed a
little bit at the boot
can't presentation so I'm not going to
spend too much time on it but but the
foot but this study was first in the
series aren't the same result that the
Pew Group had found when presenting
people with a whole range of categories
of information they found that these
were the top five most sensitive
categories of information so our results
we replicated the pew and we found the
same thing but what we showed is that
when you add the parameter when you add
what the the recipient parameter to and
and we use the the spec factorial
vignette method and I'll show you that a
little bit later is that even though
people would report our medical data is
very private or very sensitive when you
vary the recipient and it seems so
obvious you get enormous differences in
how appropriate or how acceptable it is
for information to flow to you know your
doctor yeah it's absolutely fine but
when it's your who explained why it's
only seventy percent I know
interesting because you'll see all of
the rest it's never a hundred percent
it's never like all the way to a hundred
I mean it may be how we ask the question
but
it's really about which information is
sensitive on how people perceive
distinctive
I'm not sure
yeah actually it is causing and these
are all about perceptions all of the
results are about perceptions and one
and one of the concerns that we know
needs to be addressed is the fact that
people actually don't don't have a good
sense of what can harm them so the these
are really claims about what people
judge to be sensitive and not to use
those judgments as ground truth because
when you add the parameter that what we
were trying to show is that the paradox
if when you see people behave in ways
that are incompatible with their
statements that privacy is valuable what
you're seeing is not that they don't
care about privacy but they're actually
doing things like this they're making
judgments about the appropriateness of
certain flows if you have a definition
of privacy that says any flow means that
you don't care about privacy then you
are going to see those two things as
incompatible but when you add the
variables in and you say appropriate
flow which is described in terms of
these five parameters then you're going
to see it's possible that those
behaviors are quite compatible with each
other and that kind of disappears the
paradox is I mean we have to do more
work but it it could disappear the
paradox excuse my bad grammar
so let me move on and talk a little bit
about the public information because
this was one that I haven't talked about
at all
and this gets to my question to
Alexandra and by policy or whatever it
is which is privacy interests in public
information so the same but a kind of
argument in reversed here is what the
factorial vignette survey methodology
looks like here here's the basic little
vignette and then you have these
parameters recipient subject information
type and source which is kind of
transmission principle there were ways
in which we had to simplify these these
surveys and then we had the vet we had
values for I hope you can read it it's
probably a little bit small and here are
how we operationalize now one thing to
point out is all of these are public
records so according to that policy
anything goes with these public records
right okay
first of all oh one thing I want to
remark because we're still struggling
with it we present the vignette and then
we say to people is it okay and we allow
them to do a hundred - 100 - a hundred
that's how we get the thing what we
really want is expectations and not
preferences because contextual integrity
talks about norms and your expectations
might not be the same as your
preferences so unless this I need help
with because we've tried so many
different ways of asking the question we
feel that people are often telling us
their preferences and not the
expectation but we really want to
expectations so hopefully people will
try things out and let us know but what
up this is the last slide I see your
hand I'm just gonna race through a
little bit but this is what I wanted to
show you because this is all public data
in the sense that all of the data fields
that we showed people were data from
public records so you might say and then
this is the data broker
this is checking for the information
from a government online portal and this
is you get the information by asking the
subject him or herself if you've been
following me which I'm going ah this
really this tells us that people believe
that this is the kind of data that
people should have control over so you
know me I'm often saying oh it's got
nothing to do with control people talk
about privacy as control of information
that's not the case it's about
appropriate flow but in these cases what
we're seeing here so this one says
average appropriateness of guests
receiving party host information so we
were thinking are you
iving to someone's house for a party and
it's a very fancy house and you're like
I wonder how much these people paid for
this house so you could either ask them
or you could go check up on Zillow or
what or what or Trulia or you could go
to actually public government records
yourself and find it out and same for
Bank receiving loan applicant average
appropriateness of bank receiving
applicant information and this is
property criminal record marriage status
and what you voted in the last election
which isn't available in every state but
in many state not what you purchase but
whether you voted in the most recent
election which is a public record not in
all states but in many states and this
is company receiving job applicant
information by information type and
sauce first of all you can see everybody
hates data brokers that I mean the most
consistent result we've gotten in all
our studies is that this is the thing
people find most reprehensible but you
can see that in different scenarios
people have objection to government data
open data being wide so if you are
forming a policy of how to use or make
accessible certain types of information
even though it's in public records you
need to know that you're violating
people's expectations when you make them
available in certain ways and then
finally and I'm rushing a little bit and
I see a couple of hands but I want to
get through this last thing which is
we're now looking at location data
because it's so important at the moment
we're focusing on public location and in
the law we have something called the
plain view doctrine that actually says
that if something's in public it's up
for grabs and now we want to understand
is this the way people think about
location factorial vignette methodology
we did some complicated surveys we did a
pilot and several different rounds of
surveys and the main study and so on so
I'm you you can be glancing at this
while I'm talking but basically I'm just
gonna reveal a few of the surprising
results that we found first of all the
precision of luck this was this came out
in the pilot study that the precision
matcher the answer is who thinks
precision matters now you knew I
wouldn't have asked if it if I didn't
have a surprising result for you so we
asked people things like City versus GPS
you know latitude longitude coordinates
and as you can see although they were
slightly more okay with or less not okay
with city like in San Francisco
Cynthia's in San Francisco versus York
what whereas like latitude longitude not
much difference so actually that gave us
permission to use locate the term
location for the rest of our studies
relevance of semantics this was my
favorite thing this is really important
for technology design how do you
represent location in your mobile app
like what is the operating system
generating that your mobile app is going
to use as a representation of location
so that when you ask the permission of
somebody cannot track your location or
not you switch that off does it matter
to people that you're switching of the
correct thing and what we found
is that when you say location this is an
average results I mean okay I have to
interpret it for you when you tell
people location they have a certain
response to whether something's okay or
not
but when you give it meaning you say
home look it doesn't have to be some
sensitive like at the brothel or
whatever it is it can be it can be
something very plain it's much more much
less acceptable so you can imagine the
mismatch we have now with machine
representation and what it is that
people care about okay this is just I've
got sort of ran out of time right
I'm only going to show you one thing
because it's such a lovely result we
took the Facebook privacy policy we
tagged all its elements in terms of the
contextual integrity parameters we
performed an analysis some of it other
people had done and we were just sort of
replicating but the thing we were really
interested is this idea of bloating we
were very lucky you could say because in
the middle of the study the Cambridge
analytic her scandal blew up and
Facebook made a huge implicit say
improvement in the policy basically
becoming much more specific with like
all all the sender's all the attributes
all the recipients and so on there were
numerous more incomplete flows which we
are saying are ambiguous if you don't
specify the recipient you can see it
makes a difference to how people respond
but what we found is bloating so if you
provide a sentence to someone like this
and they're there I don't know 76 of
these in the Facebook policy looks very
particular very specific but when you
actually matter
MoDOT this has a hundred and twenty six
permutations so if you're thinking that
someone is reading a policy and actually
has any idea what practices that policy
actually covers now this is just one and
there 76 of these not all of them are
bloat bloaty
in quite the same way but you can
imagine how complex it is sorry and I
know there were questions and I'm out of
time what's that a few a few minutes for
questions
[Applause]
okay.we when you're doing the studies
example infinite use data do you have
some weights is English like I can see
negative like this is it not okay a
response the person's belief that the
data broker shouldn't be sharing that
information or that somebody shouldn't
be getting it from a bit of burger or of
a preference or belief right occasion I
guess then outside of the flow where the
information comes from we just say maybe
they're saying not that the house guests
shouldn't have gotten the home price
from Zillow but that Zillow shouldn't
have had that information in the first
place and is there a way in the study
that you know you were getting at one of
those and not the other one I don't
think we can I don't think we can
distinguish between those two yeah
no Micah had a shirt when you talk about
being interested in expectations not
purposes you mean
positive expectations what people think
will will typically happen in that
situation or distinguishing between
normative things that I would like to be
true but are not requiring no no it's
what I expect and it may not be what I
want and and I mean the example I use is
well it's just it's not positive or
negative it's just what I expect
yes yes so right so when I talk about
norms as contextual informational norms
I'm talking about the way in which we
think that if people behave normatively
they're behaving correctly so I am
standing in front of you in this on this
platform you are all sitting politely if
someone started throwing eggs at me that
would be unexpected I guess unpleasant
as well but but part of the reason you
know that the expectation will often
define what's appropriate I mean there's
a whole theory of norms and sometimes
norms turn out not to be right well not
to be good and society moves on and
norms change so I do mean it in a in a
in an ethical way it's both common
practice and it's expected but it may
not be preferred so I don't want to send
my my transcript that shows I got a C in
calculus but I know it's expected of me
and I'm not surprised when somebody asks
me that
perfect that's the but you can talk yeah
you can said as you wish it may not be
ethically defensible but it's expected
but if you say what would you prefer I
would say I'd like to just redact that
grade but okay to be continued yeah so
in other words we just kind of sorry
yeah if I have this data yeah and this
is really important and I didn't get to
it
which is that when we when we actually
provided inference then it went way down
right so they might have said a you know
not so bad about location then we gave
place dip in appropriateness but when we
said to infer that you have a chronic
disease it plummeted so that was
definitely significant and I think here
again it relates to your point that and
here knowledge versus expectation is
very important because if it turns out
that people don't realize that frequency
or granularity for example actually
enable inference then their expectations
are really out of sync with what they
should be thinking and that's the kind
of educates the content in that's the
way and I know we we had a little bit of
that discussion in which people's
ignorance means that when you do the
kinds of studies we're doing you aren't
necessarily getting the right answers if
you want to set policy that can actually
limit the harms of exposure of certain
kinds of information anyway okay thank
you very much everybody
[Applause]
[Music]